a deadly rockslide at Glacier National
Park is prompting a warning about
potential dangers for tourists a family
of five was driving along this popular
Montana Road when their car was hit by
falling rocks
a teenage girl inside that car was
killed Meg Oliver shows us how this
accident happened Pat Cummings says she
was driving down this road in Glacier
National Park when traffic stop
amid sounds of horror I could clearly
hear a woman crying frantically
screaming you know please help her
someone please just help her Park
officials confirm a car driven by a
family of five from Utah was caught in a
rock fall enough debris to fill the bed
of a pickup truck some of the stones a
foot in diameter whether it's rain
whether it's wind you know all of those
things can cause rock to fall but Rock
fall of this magnitude is very unusual a
14 year old girl in the car was killed
her parents and two siblings were
injured if there had been more cars
probably closer together I do think it
could have been worse it happened here
on the 50 mile long going-to-the-sun
road driven by about two million people
every year the roads last Rock fall
death was more than two decades ago and
the danger is not always preventable
it's a little bit tough to inspect the
mountains above the road rocks are
continually shedding as part of that
geologic process for CBS this morning
I'm Meg Oliver these people now know
about that the danger if you didn't know
before it's ripping down roads like that
you know I've always looking it's not
that that's gonna prevent you from now
incident like you see the signs but you
don't think it's gonna happen and then
even if it does it feels very much out
of your control absolutely and it is and
the roads call going to the Sun it's
interesting to make thank you